this morning a search is intensifying
for missing five-year-old boy in a
Chicago suburb the parents of Andrew AJ
friend told police they last saw their
son on Wednesday evening when he went to
bed
they say they realized he was missing
Thursday morning crowds gathered at a
vigil for AJ over the weekend Dean
Reynolds is following this story for us
and explains why police may now be
turning their attention to the boy's
family investigators in Crystal Lake
Illinois say they're focusing their
search on the family's home where five
year old aged a friend allegedly went
missing on Wednesday police say canine
teams have found no evidence of AJ
leaving the home and that dogs picked up
his scent in the trunk of his parents
car we're just extremely worried AJ's
father Andrew French senior has been
pleading for his son safe return AJ
please come home we love you very much
friends spent at least three hours at
the Crystal Lake Police Department on
Saturday if anybody knows anything about
where Andrew jr. is please please
contact the crisp Lake Police Department
the Illinois Department of Children and
Family Services says it's been in
contact with the boy's parents since
2013 when he was born with opiates in
his system amid allegations of neglect
against his mother Joanne Cunningham the
department says it took AJ into
protective custody when he was about a
month old but then returned him home
about 18 months later Illinois DCFS says
more recent allegations of neglect by
both parents proved to be unfounded and
that Cunningham agreed to reenter drug
treatment when Cunningham since she may
be considered a suspect in her son's
disappearance her attorney says he told
her to remain silent
miss Cunningham doesn't know what
happened to AJ and had nothing to do
with the disappearance of AJ on Saturday
Crystal Lake Police Chief Jim black told
the Chicago Tribune the fact that both
parents have stopped cooperating with us
certainly raises our suspicions police
have not announced any arrests in the
case
for CBS this morning Dean Reynolds
Chicago